હ
[Musique]
he
autour du monde des amoureux de la
lecture apportent des livres aux
habitants des îles lointaines perdu dans
l'immensité de la
mer en Suède l'équipage du navire
bibliothèque
rodloga navigue sur la mer
Baltique ces marins pas comme les autres
ravitaille les populations isolées de
m000
histoires en Indonésie Ridouan capitaine
du
colit vogue dans le détroit de floress
au sud de l'Î
S avec des bénévoles et des pêcheurs il
transporte dans ses cales la magie de la
littérature en Europe et en Asie ces
bateaux tissent des liens entre les
hommes avec des milliers de pages et
d'histoire
[Musique]
sur la côte orientale de la Suède entre
le lac Malaren et la mer Baltique voici
Stockholm
[Musique]
traversé par d'innombrables canaux la
capitale de la Suède est une ville bâtie
sur les
[Musique]
eaux Stockholm fait partie du plus grand
archipel de la mer Baltique qui compte
plus de 24000
î
[Musique]
pour voyager à travers cet espace
remarquable une multitude de bateaux
sillonnent cette zone
[Musique]
maritime amaré en plein centrre-eville
voici le r Loga un bateau de croisière
qui navigue depuis 19
151 ce matin ce ne sont pas des
passagers qui embarquent mais des
livres chaque année pendant une semaine
à l'automne puis au printemps le rod
Loga se transforme en bateau
bibliothèque alors sur ces caisse rouge
vous avez un chiffre
et bien le même chiffre est marqué sur
les
étagères il faut donc les faire
correspond Anik est la responsable de
cette bibliothèque pas comme les
autres ce matin avec son équipe elle
réceptionne tous les ouvrages pour la
semaine alors ici on manque un peu
d'espace on va enlever ses caiss en
premier c'est pour lundi
et
oui c'est le dernier voyage d'Anita sur
ce bateau dans de jours elle passera la
main à Maria uneutre
bithéire là on embarque à peu près 3000
livres pour le
voyage mais notre stock global est
beaucoup plus important car il y a tous
les prês en
cours on a vraiment tout ici des livres
pour enfants
des polares des livres sur les animaux
et la nature et beaucoup de livres sur
les
bateaux on est vraiment comme une
bibliothèque
classique classique ou presque pendant
une semaine le reloga va parcourir plus
de 200 km à travers l'archipel afin de
proposer ses livres aux
insulair une véritable bibliothèque
itinérante ok les filles alors voyons
voir tout ça ça me semble pas mal du
tout tout a l'air bien
rangé au fond on a le coin enfant bon et
bien bravo les filles vous avez bien
[Rires]
travaillé à la tête du rodloga le
capitaine
johanman cela fait 19 ans qu'il effectue
ce
trajet avant le départ il transmet à
l'équipe quelques consignes de
sécurité sur le pont vous avez des
gilets de sauvetage un peu
partout ici dans ces caisses blanches et
on en a mis d'autres là-bas au fond
parce qu'il avait plus assez de place
ici vous avez également des bouées de
sauvetage il y en a tout autour du
bateau
parfois la mer peut être un peu forte
mais le plus risqué c'est de heurter un
rocher ça peut
arriver le risque alors c'est que les
livres tombent des étagères par exemple
et que quelqu'un s'en prenne un sur la
tête on peut se faire très
mal ce service de prêt de livre mis en
place par la Bibliothèque régionale de
Stockholm est une vieille institution
qui existe depuis 1953
[Musique]
à l'origine il était destiné aux
pêcheurs et insulaires qui ne quittaient
jamais leur
[Musique]
île le bateau bibliothèque lève l'encre
et entame cette première session de
printemps c'est parti pour une semaine
de navigation à travers les îles de la
mer
Baltique
le navire met le cap vers l'extrême nord
de l'archipel première étape de cette
tournée l'île d'arolma à 80 km de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Stockholm au sud-ouest de l'île delaie
en Indonésie voici le de pambous Swan
10000 habitants y vivent essentiellement
des familles de
pêcheurs dans ce pays au 17000 î le
bateau est le meilleur ami de
l'homme depuis toujours la navigation a
joué un rôle fondamental pour unifier
les nombreux peuples de l'archipel qu'on
nommait autrefois le monde
malai pambutan a une particularité une
richesse que ne possède aucun autre
village de pêcheur une grande
bibliothèque tous ces livres qui
remplissent les rayonnages sont envoyés
par des centaines de
donateurs cette générosité pambutwan la
doit à son bateau
bibliothèque ici dans le 4e pays le plus
peuplé de la planète la moitié des
enfants n'ont accès qu'à des manuels
scolaires son toujoursux qui vivent sur
les î les plus isolé le bateau
bibliothèque de Pan brave la mre des
Célèbes pour aller à le rencontre c'est
cette initiative qui a touché le cœur
des
[Musique]
Indonésiens le soleil va bientôt se
lever son prê pour voyage de 4
[Musique]
jours expédition vérifie son
itinéraire ici c'est le village de
pambusan on voit le détroit de
mandar on partira bientôt vers l'île de
tonyaman il faudra naviguer plusieurs
heures dans le détroit de mandar pour
s'y rendre en 3 jours on devra s'arrêter
sur plusieurs
îles ce marin pêcheur expérimenté est
aussi un écrivain spécialiste de la
culture
indonésienne 5 mois par an il part en
mère loin de sa femme et de ses trois
enfants pour aller partager le plaisir
de
[Musique]
lire à chaque voyage Ridouan accueille à
bord des étudiants bénévoles qui
deviennent des membres d'équipage à
partentière une façon pour le capitaine
de reconnecter les jeunes à leur
tradition maritime et de les inciter à
aimer et à respecter l'océan qui en a
bien
besoin ici pas de tri ni de collecte de
déchets tout est déversé dans l'océan et
tout revient la plage ressemble à une
décharge ça r triste et c'est plutôt
ironique si on considère ce que je fais
dans la
vie c'est comme une claque en plein
visage parce que j'ai toujours beaucoup
de visiteurs
ici je ne leur cache pas ce
problème
les sacs plasti et les ordures n'cheront
pas l'embarcation de ridouine
d'effectuer sa mission
culturelle mission sacré pour le
capitaine après chaque expédition le
bateau est remonté sur la plage à l'abri
des vagues souvent violentes de l'océan
Pacifique prière étape le remettre à
l'eau une tâche
compliqué
avec une centaine de livres en sout le
col P au moins 4 ton pour arriver à le
mettre à l'eau l'aide des hommes du
village est
[Musique]
nécessaire person pour mettre
B rester coincé pendant la
manvre
[Applaudissements]
tout est prêt il ne reste plus qu'à
lever
l'encre
le bateau bibliothèque a quitté la
capitale suédoise et son effervescence
pour le calme de
[Musique]
l'archipel il serpente au milieu de
multiples î récif ou î qui s'étendent à
perte de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vue pour se repérer le bateau suit des
balises de navigation
elle signale les nombreux rochers qui
affleurent à la surface de
l'eau
ar Johanna Carman et son équipe sont sur
le qui
viventis un rocher là-bas au
fond normalement il devrait y avoir la
balise à côté mais je ne la vois
pas ah oui attention il est là juste
devant
on a vraiment failli se le prendre
c'était Mo
une je na depuis que je suis tout
[Musique]
petit j'ai toujours aimé les
bateau j'ai eu ma première barque quand
j'avais 5
ans je continue toujours à
naviguer
le rodloga arrive sur l'île d'arolma la
plus septentrionale de
[Musique]
l'archipel avec ses maisons
traditionnelles en bois et ses forêts de
pain arolma est une île typique de
[Musique]
l'archipel
à peine 70 ames vivent à l'année une
population multipliée par 10 chaque
été les premiers habitants sont déjà
présents avec seulement de passages par
an le bateau est très
attendu
regardeil qui arrive avec S livr à
rendre
beaucoup
[Musique]
hej
bon
ja nu lägger jag Kassar här sen
för livr il a
Mo peuvent en emprunter autant qu'ils
veulent il n'y a pas de
limite personne na jamais vouu tout
emprter dans
donc en général ça se passe
[Musique]
bien sur le rod Loga pour emprunter pas
de carte individuelle mais un compte
commun pour tous les habitants de
[Musique]
l'île chaque résident pourra à loisir
échanger ses livres avec ceux de son
[Musique]
voisin et c'est vraiment un rituel pour
moi de venir sur ce
bateau je pourrais emprunter à terre
mais c'est un peu plus loin et c'est
plus sympa sur ce
bateau là je cherche surtout des polars
et
[Musique]
desillers
après 45 minutes à qu le reprend sa
route vers la prochaine
[Musique]
île le temps pour Anik de dire au revoir
à son équipe är
jättefätte on arrive dans des îles
vraiment
magnifiques mais malheureusement on a
même pas le temps de descendre pour
visiter c'est une semaine très intense
c'est pas vraiment des vacances
d'ailleurs an m'a formé pour reprendre
la direction du bateau l'an prochain et
c'était vraiment
passionnant fin du voyage pour Anik qui
remet les clés du navire à Maria au
revoir vous allez me manquer je vous
confie le bateau salut les
filles salut
salut ultime étape de cette journée
l'île de swartloga à l'est de
l'archipel une terre isolée batue par
les vents difficile à atteindre en
raison des eaux peu profondes qui
l'entourent
[Musique]
une île à l'état sauvage sans au
courante ni
[Musique]
électricité carl mobac est l'une des se
personnes qui vivent ici à
l'année ce charpentier originaire de
Stockholm s'est installé sur avec sa
femme il y a 22
ans depuis il ne rate aucun passage du R
Loga il n'y a rien sur cette île pas
d'électricité pas d'eau
courante pour avoir de l'eau il faut la
puiser dans un
puit je n'ai pas d'internet
pas de
smartphone rien de tout
ça et je suis plus
heureux j'aime les
livres on revient dans 6 mois à
l'automne end au revoir encore
merci
fin de journée pour le bateau
bibliothèque demain le rodloga mettra le
cap vers le sud de l'archipel ù de
jeunes lecteurs l'attendent depuis de
longs
[Musique]
mois
[Applaudissements]
en Indonésie le colic puji s'apprête à
prendre le
[Musique]
large mais le départ est difficile la
mer est agitée les vages repousse s
cesse le bateau vers la
rive le moteur ne démarre pas mais tout
finit par
[Musique]
s'arranger ça y est c'est bon on peut y
aller on y
[Musique]
va
la mer est encore calme avant le mauvais
temps qui s'annonce Ridan en profite
pour enseigner des leçons de voile au
jeunes
[Applaudissements]
bénévoles
al merasakan APA bersama pelaut en
terhad
ilantage le pays en apprenant la
navigation et en nous cyant nous les
pêche c'est quel
chose orang tua Kita Yang Seang pelaut
Seang
nelayanai
relawan pas familier avec la mer et la
vie sur un bateau même si la maison de
mon enfant se trouvait en zone
côtière je n'avais jamais appris tout
cela avant ici j'ai appris à interpréter
les éléments
[Applaudissements]
naturels en route un marin fait une
offrande plutôt sur
un uf c'est un rituel imuable pour tous
les navigurs
Indonésiens on fait un rituel parce que
en ce moment on passe dans une zone
sacrée sur la côte ouest de si de
nombreux pêcheurs c qu'il y a des
espritsci c'est notre manière d'obtenir
le permission pour passer et de leur
demander de ne pas perturber notre
voyage
[Musique]
le vent commence à souffler fort et les
risques de naufrage sont bien réels
[Musique]
la première étape de la tournée du
bateau bibliothèque est encore à une
journée de navigation mais Ridouan doit
renoncer il prend la décision de changer
de cap et se dirige vers un village
beaucoup plus
proche les courants sont de plus en plus
forts et les marins ont le plus grand
mal à manœuvrer pour se mettre à l'abri
dans l'embouchure de la baie au milieu
de la mangrove
les marins savent s'adapter ridouine et
son équipage ne reprendront pas la mer
ce
soir demain c'est ici qu'ils
installeront leur bibliothèque ambulante
près de ce petit village gondam grve où
l'on cultive la
[Musique]
crevette
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le bateau bibliothèque poursuit sa
tournée
printanière il rejoint l'île de swarzo
l'une des plus grandes de la partie
centrale de
[Musique]
l'archipel swarzo est une vaste plaine
où se succèd lacs intérieurs forêt et
terres
agricoles véritable avre de paix c'est
une destination prisée des Suédois
l'été c'est aussi une des raresî de
l'archipel a possédé une
école en tout 22 élèves de 4 à 18 ans
cohabitent dans cet espace
[Musique]
privilégié on a tous les livres c'est
parti Annette maîtresse en maternelle
accompagne et s
leoga biblthèque à l'école mais ça ne
suffit pas et les enfants aim bienter de
nouveau
livr on lit beaucoup en
[Musique]
maternel bonjour je vous prends les
livres regarde celui-ci Sven il
t'intéresse
oui et voilà c'est fini oh ça bouge
maîtresse c'est parce qu'il y a du vent
dehors comme c'est très loin pour nous
d'aller dans une autre bibliothèque
c'est vraiment extra que ce bateau
puisse venir sur notre
île les ados profitent également de cet
espaceia 12 ans et pour cette fille
d'agriculteur rien ne remplace un
livre pour moi c'est super important de
venir sur le
bateau
je trouve que c'est mieux pour
l'environnement d'emprunter plutôt que
d'acheter et personnellement je préfère
lire des vrais livres plutôt que lire
sur mon smartphone ou écouter des
fichiers véritable lien social le
rodeloga semble remplir parfaitement sa
mission de bibliothèque de
proximité la difficulté ici c'est
d'avoir des livres pour tous les âges
dans un espace
réduit et là ça fonctionne plutôt
bien quand tout le monde part avec un
livre c'est là qu'on voit qu'on a
réussi pour assurer la diffusion de ces
livres le bateau peut aussi compter sur
des relais
précieux c'est bon tu asez de ce pour
nous
amarrer
es sûr que c'est bien
attaché c'est
bonber 70 ans gère depuis 10 ans la
petite bibliothèque de
l cette productrice de tomate profite du
passage du Roga pour compléter son
fond Jes
livr
pouzterle isis
d' tu cheres quelque chose de léger oui
je cherche un livre errotique soft ah
ben ça il faut demander au fill moi je
sais
pas le bateau est important pour
nous nous avons une bonne bibliothèque
mais là c'est un bon
complément on pase de place pour stock
trop de livr de toute fa
en tout cas pour nous ce bateau c'est un
peu comme le Père Noël qui passerait au
printemps allez à bientôt la prochaine
fois karine a fait le plein de livre
pour les 6 mois à venir jusqu'au
prochain passage du
[Musique]
bateau
avant de rejoindre la prochaine île le
capitaine fait un détour par un bras de
mer exceptionnel
[Musique]
entre les îles meya et
sermeya ce canal protégé révèle un décor
[Musique]
enchantire
Andress le skiper connait bien ce
passage il faut un peu seom entre les
pierres
ici c'est vra un peu difficile de
naviguer c'est vraiment un endroit
remarquable très caractéristique de
l'archipel je pense vraiment qu'il faut
montrer ça aux gens
[Musique]
fin de journée pour l'équipage du
rloga
biéolm une île proche de
Stockholm pour ce séjour elle s'est
porté volontaire pour être la chef
cuisinière du
bateau alors écraser de pommes de terre
à l'échalotte et huile
d'olive et le saumon au pesto de petit
pois et
roquett bravo à tous pour votre
travail
l all c'est super tette envie commune
que ça
fonctionne et on a tous envie de
proposer ce service aux gens le mieux
possible demain le rod Loga poursuivra
son périple jusqu'à son retour à
[Musique]
Stockholm pour l'heure c'est sous un
clair de lune de printemps que toute
l'équipe
[Musique]
s'endor de retour en Indonésie sur l'île
de
sulaweesi l'équipage du colikpji
s'apprête à se lever il est 5h30 du
matin aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour
l'équipage a rendez-vous avec ses
lecteurs Wana une jeune bénévole de 25
ans prépare les repas pour ses h
coéquipiers au menu tempé et
riz je me suis engagé sur ce bateau pour
notre mission nous tient à cur et j
participe comme cuisinière mais on n pas
encore de
réfrigérateur alors hier on a apporté
avec nous des œufs et des nouilles pour
cuisiner pour avir un repas frais il
faut parfois acheter des ingrédients
auprès des villageois près
d'ici l'année dernière la jeune femme a
proposé son aide au capitaine
ridouine élevé par un père pêcheur qui
l'emmen fréquemment en mer elle veut
aujourd'hui partager son expérience
[Applaudissements]
maritime Ridouan et son équipe n'ont pas
une minute à perdre ils acheminent
l'ivre matériel vers la plage pour
établir le camp de lecture
les enfants sont fous de joie ils
connaissent bien ce joli bateau à Mar
dans la baie et tous les trésors qu'il
transporte je veux un livre sur les
coros c'est la 5è fois que le bateau
bibliothèque passe dans leur
village
[Musique]
les enfants
s'impatientent il s' des premiers livres
déposés et plonge dans ces univers de
papier qui les font
voyager
akang je lis un livre sur les
tunnels et tu l'as déjà lu ce livre non
tu as des livres chez toi non j'ai pas
de Liv à la maison il y en a à
l'école sonr
é les étudiants aent les jeunes à
choisir leur livr le don un coup de main
pour la
lecture ce sont surtout des livres pour
enfants mais il y a aussi des livres
pour les
adolescents
en premier lieu on privilégie des livres
qui sont visuellement stimulants pour
les
enfants qui sont color et rempl
d'illustration on préère également les
livres à rel Conn paril arrive que les
enfants les mains mouillées lorsquil les
[Musique]
manipul contement à la moitié des
enfants de son pays rid a la chance
d'entrer dans le monde des livres très
jeune sa mère était
enseignante aujourd'hui face au bonheur
des enfants il a du mal à cacher son
émotion ça r
heureux ça nous touche
beaucoup ça nous inspire de voir les
enfants tenir un
livre
VO c'est
merveilleux quand on voit ça on sait que
quelque chose sera différent après notre
départ les enfants m'inpirent
beaucoup je ne suis pas payé pour faire
ça mais c'est une expérience qui apporte
beaucoup de
positif c'est une expérience
extraordinaire et ça nous donne
l'énergie de
continuer ja dari aku tidak menyentuh
[Musique]
topimuama siapa
Bawa
[Musique]
next
le bateau bibliothèque entame la
dernière ligne droite de son marathon
des
[Musique]
îles pour Maria et son équipe chaque
matinée est l'occasion de revoir
l'itinéraire du bateau afin de
l'optimiser tu vois Mar là je trouve
qu'il y a un peu trop de temps entre ces
desolument
on retourne toujours dans les mêmes
îles on a un itinéraire bien
travaillé mais on le regarde souvent
pour voir si on ne pourrait pas rajouter
des îles plus éloignées mais avant il
faut en parler au
capitaine plusieurs bibliothèques
insulaires ont récemment fermé leur PES
et certaines écoles peent à renouvel le
ST de
livre
leoga est donc plus que jamais
[Musique]
indispensable tiens Louise voilà ton
ticket bon alors qu'est-ce qu'il a
disponible je pense aux personnes âgées
qui vivent sur l'île à mon papa ma maman
c'est important pour
eux c'est vraiment un trésor culturel
d'avoir un bateau qui vient deux fois
par
an j'prte des livres pour soutenir
l'activité mais qu'est-ce que tu nous
racontes encore comme histoire des
histoires c'est ma
maman ça fait des années que je lis
avant je tenais même la poste sur l'île
et j'avais improvisé une petite
bibliothèque
dedans
depuis plus de 50 ans des bateaux
bibliothèque comme le rloga l'archipel
de Stockholme pour apporter aux
insulaires ce service culturel si
[Musique]
précieux il a l'air lourd celui non pas
trop plutôt un des moins lourds en fait
une tradition resta ancrée dans l'esprit
des plus anciens habitants Eva Westin
effectue ce rituel depuis des décennies
avec toujours le même
enthousiasme vous voulez un
sac non j'ai ma caisse regardez ah oui
c'est mieux que les sacs en
plastique je pense à un livre pour
vous peut-être ici ah c'est à ça que tu
penses
[Musique]
nous ne sommes plus que c personnes à
être enregistré sur
l'île mais heureusement beaucoup de RET
VI dans le mais
second moi maintenant maintenant que je
suis là je ne partirai plus
[Musique]
le rodeloga gagne les récifs de l'île de
sandame un port de plaisance devenu
célèbre pour ses polars à succès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour Maria et son équipe c'est bientôt
la fin du séjour et l'heure du
bilan si vous avez des suggestions ou
des commentaires pour la prochaine fois
je pense qu'on devrait prendre plus de
temps
ass derrière table desetours il faudrait
aussi trouver un endroit pour stocker
les retours rapidement sans avoir à les
ranger tout de
suite B ça y est c'est la fin du
voyage en tout cas je trouve qu'on a
fait un bon travail pour une première
fois je suis très
contente il faut continuer comme ça tout
simplement c'est probable que l'on
retraaille ensemble à nouveau en tout
cas je
l'espère
[Musique]
le rodloga quitte sans dame et continue
sa
route ce navire de la connaissance
poursuit sa mission à travers la mer
Baltique celle d'aller au plus près des
habitants et à travers la lecture
continuer de les faire
[Musique]
rêver
à gondamang grve sur l'île de soulaie
dans le sud de l'Indonésie l'équipage du
colic aimerait reprendre la mer au plus
vite mais les conditions climatiques se
détériorent le départ est
[Musique]
retardé la météo s'annonce vraiment
mauvaise pour les prochains
jours avant de partir les homme de
l'équipage décide de se rendre à la
mosquée il traverse des bassins de
culture de crevette la principale source
de revenu des villageois du
coin il faut faire vite ils sont en
retard car même loin de chez eux rien ne
justifie qu'il rate la prière du
vendredi c'est obligatoire pour les
hommes musulmans mais la distance entre
ici et chez moi est de moins de 75 km
alors ça me permet de ne pas désobéir à
cette règle de
l'islam
on demande la bénédiction de Dieu pour
arriver
saint on lui demande la prospérité et la
chance pendant que nous serons en
[Musique]
merangsaku rakyatku
Semu
[Musique]
oranga cari ini
Tiga ya bisa di sini
ya
Anak les enfants peuvent encore profiter
des marins bibliothécaires qui organis
pour eux un dernier je dessin les images
et les couleurs inspiré par les
[Musique]
livres
il est temps maintenant de plier bagage
de ranger les livres qui seront bientôt
entre les mains d'autres
enfants mais l'océan encore une fois
dicte sa
loi la sécurité passe avant tout quand
vient le temps de prendre la mer la
météo peut tout changer
pour le moment la température n'est pas
très
favorable le vent est trop fort pour
prendre la mer c'est pour cette raison
qu'on doit être flexible dans notre
[Musique]
organisation décide d'annuler la tournée
du bateau bibliothèque et de rentrer au
[Musique]
port si on voulait aller là-bas comment
on devrait positionner la voile pour le
moment elle est à droite alors à GAE à
gauche
ouais le voyage du colici a tourné court
mais le capitaine va reprendre la mer au
plus vite car d'autres enfants attendent
ces livres et il ne veut pas les
[Musique]
décevoir sur la mer Baltique en Suède
sur la mer de floress en Indonésie des
bateaux bibliothèqu voguent vers des
îles toujours plus éloignées à bord des
marins amoureux des livres ouvrent
l'imaginaire et élargissent l'horizon de
ceux qui vivent loin de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout
[Musique]